today we are a country divided or at
least that's what we're told we are torn
apart by immigration education guns and
health care health care is ugly and it
is loud so loud that it threatens to
drown out everything else
[Applause]
but what if underneath all the noise
were not divided what if the things that
we don't ask about are the things that
we most agree upon it turns out that
when we ask the right questions the
answers are startling because we agree
not on health care but on something more
important we agree on health for 20
years I've been obsessed with one
question what do we what do all of us
need in order to be healthy as a college
student in 1995 I spent months talking
with physicians at a chaotic Hospital in
Boston asking them what's the one-finger
patients most need to be healthy they
shared the same story again and again
one that I've heard hundreds of
variations of sense they say every day I
see a patient with an asthma
exacerbation and I prescribe a
controller medication but I know she is
living in a mold infested apartment or I
see a kid with an ear infection and I
prescribe antibiotics but I know there
is no food at home and I don't ask about
those issues because there's nothing I
can do now it seemed that it shouldn't
be so complicated to design a doctor's
visit around what people actually need
to be healthy so I created hopefully
it's an organization enabling thousands
of physicians and other caregivers to
ask their patients what do you need to
be healthy and then prescribed those
things fruits and
doubles heat in the winter electricity
to refrigerate their medication and we
then navigated patients to those
resources in their communities the model
works Mass General Hospital study found
that navigating patients to essential
resources is associated with
improvements in blood pressure and
cholesterol levels similar to
introducing a new drug but without all
the side effects so two decades later
what's changed it's now widely
recognized that just 20% of health
outcomes are tied to medical care
whereas up to 70% are tied to healthy
behaviors and what's called the social
determinants of health basically
everything that happens to us for that
vast majority of time when we're not in
the doctor's office or the hospital
healthcare executives now routinely
remind us that our zip code matters more
than our genetic code and one healthcare
publication even recently had the
audacity to describe the social
determinants of health as the feel-good
buzzword of the year now there's been
some action too over the past decades
six major health care providers and
insurers have committed over six hundred
million dollars to affordable housing
recognizing that it reduces infant
infant mortality and increases life
expectancy but let's be honest is our
three point five trillion dollar health
care system fundamentally designed to
create health absolutely not
take access to healthy food not long ago
a teenage boy shows up at a hospital in
Baltimore losing weight just as his
doctors are huddled up figuring out
which metabolic panels and blood pet
tests to run one of my colleagues asked
out loud do you think he might be hungry
it turned out that this kid had been
kicked out of his housing and literally
hadn't had a meal in weeks
he said he was so relieved that somebody
finally asked me somehow we've created a
healthcare system we're asking
patient are you hungry is so far outside
the bounds of what counts as health care
that we mostly fail or forget to ask
altogether we're doctors lament a
hospital's no third sandwich policy
meaning that if you're a hungry patient
in the ER you can have only two free
sandwiches but as many MRIs as the
doctor orders we're at twenty sixteen in
the state of Texas
they spent 1.2 billion dollars on the
medical cost of malnutrition instead of
on access to healthy food we're a
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services program stratifies hungry
patients so that some get access to food
and some get information about food with
the justification that doing nothing for
hungry patients a standard and usual
care in this country and that's just
food the same is true for housing
electricity the bottom line is health
care may be changing but not by enough
and certainly not fast enough we asked
the wrong questions of our doctors of
our patients but also of our citizens we
asked about and argue about health care
but how do voters think about health no
one could tell us the answer to that
question so we launched a new initiative
and hired a polling firm to ask voters
across the country what do you need to
be healthy what was so striking about
this was that no one has any clue what
we are talking about in health care
voters do not think the social
determinants of health is a feel-good
phrase they actually hate it
what uneducated person came up with that
language one of the voters said or my
favorite was the guy who said you're
killing me but when you strip away all
the ridiculousness of our language in
health care we know exactly what creates
health so take Charlotte North Carolina
we had two focus groups one of African
American Democratic women and one of
white Republican women and we asked them
if you had 100
how would you spend it to buy health in
your community
turns out they agree nearly to the last
percentage point first they agree that
health care only sort of impacts health
so they choose to spend the majority of
their dollars outside of hospitals and
clinics and second they agree on what
creates health spending 19% on
affordable housing and about 25% on
access to healthy food so I am sure you
were thinking this has got to be a fluke
but it's not white and Latino male swing
voters in Seattle white and
african-american Democratic voters in
Cleveland
white male Republicans in Dallas
low-income white Democrats in
Hendersonville North Carolina their
answers are strikingly similar with all
of them choosing to spend more money on
healthy food and safe housing than they
would on hospitals and health centers
when you ask the right questions it
becomes pretty clear we may be fractured
on health care in this country but we
are unified on health the thing that
I've been struggling with is why why do
we agree on health we agree on health
because it is common sense we all know
that the things that we need to get
healthy medicine and medical care are
not the things we need to be healthy to
not get sick in the first place
but we also agree because of common
experience in a study of 5,000 patients
24 percent of the patients with
commercial health insurance meaning they
had a job still ran out of food or
struggled to find housing or
transportation or other essential
resources 24 percent and we saw the same
thing in our focus groups nearly every
voter knew what it meant to struggle
either themselves or their families or
their neighbors one of those white
Republican women in Charlotte was a
waitress struggling to stay awake with
an enormous big gulp soda she just
looked exhausted
and she was she told us that she worked
two jobs but still cannot afford a
membership to the Y but it was okay that
she couldn't go to the gym she said
because she also could not afford gas
and watch ten miles to and from work
every single day listening to her I felt
this familiar panic rise in me the
residue of my own childhood when I was
ten years old my father lay on the
living-room floor in the grips of one of
his many depressions as I crouched next
to him he told me that he wanted to kill
himself my father lived but he struggled
to work and my family survived but we
teetered down one paycheck relying on my
mom's school teacher's salary even as a
little kid I knew we lived in the shadow
of financial and emotional collapse this
is really hard to say because it's taken
me 25 years to be honest with myself
that this is why I do this work knowing
that my father needed health care to
recover but to be healthy my family
needed something else we needed a decent
income and knowing as so many do more
than I that panic when the basics
threatened to slip away to the voters
and our focus groups the solutions were
straightforward as one of those white
Republican women and Charlotte said
instead of putting all this money into
health care put it into affordable
housing you know like take it and
distribute it differently it turns out
that when you have the right language
and you ask the right questions the
answers become remarkably clear and
unanimous what we know is that despite
all the noise the plan for health care
in this country is that there is no plan
but we have something more powerful than
any politicians bill
any candidates platform anything tanks
policy statement we have our common
sense and our common experience so I ask
if you are a healthcare executive do you
know how many of your patients run out
of food or struggle to pay the rent at
the end of the month is that data on
your scorecard shaping your business and
your bonuses if you are a politician
will you continue to fight on the
scorched earth of healthcare or will you
act on what your voters with Democratic
and Republican voters alike already know
which is that good wages healthy food
and safe housing our health and for the
rest of us for the citizens of this
country will we demand accountability to
what we know to be true which is that
our common sense our common experience
makes us the experts and what it takes
to be healthy this moment as it turns
out is not about changing Minds it is
about something more powerful it is
about changing the questions we ask and
quieting the noise to hear each other's
answers it is about the radical
possibility that we the patients we the
physicians we the caregivers we the
healthcare executives and yes even we
the people that we agree and it is now
time in fact long overdue for us to
marshal the courage to hear those
answers and to act upon them thank you
[Applause]